in today's morning rounds American pets
are getting fatter a new study shows the
nationwide obesity epidemic now includes
our pets one in three dogs and cats are
overweight or obese and the extra fat
can cause life-threatening conditions
Don Dahler is at a dog park in New York
City with New York City with the warning
signs for pet owners Don good morning
good morning the ASPCA says there are
about 78 million pet dogs in this
country and almost 88 million pet cats
and unfortunately many of them are
alarmingly overweight busy lifestyles
and unhealthy diets are wreaking havoc
on our pets overweight and obesity and
our cats and dogs has increased by a
hundred and sixty to a hundred and
seventy percent dr. Kurt Berninger is
the lead veterinary researcher behind a
study by Banfield Pet Hospital right now
one out of three cats and dogs are
overweight he attributes this increase
to a number of factors lack of exercise
too much food and a changing attitude
towards our pets we are starting to
consider pets more and more to be
members of our family and we'd like to
communicate with them and show our
affection to them by offering them
treats and it can be pretty easy for us
to offer too many treats in a single day
to our pets that's a problem because
just as in humans lugging around all
that extra weight can be hazardous to
your pets health for example heart
disease and respiratory disease are
something that we'll see type 2 diabetes
is something that will see with cats
that are obese and we can see other
diseases that are linked with dogs being
overweight so how do you know if your
pet needs the treadmill treatment after
all animals especially dogs come in all
different shapes and sizes
dr. Bernie gar says you can use this as
a general guide looking at your pet from
above he says you should see a distinct
tuck at your dog or cat's waist and from
the side you should be able to easily
feel but not see its ribs but a Fido is
too fat or fluffy is well too fluffy
there is something you can do a
about it you can forget that your pet
needs exercise to Deborah Montgomery is
with Morris animal in in New Jersey a
kind of daycare for pets where they can
run trails or swim or just play what
advice do you have for people who don't
have access to this kind of place you
know even taking a walk you get a chance
to bond with your pets
it's just something simple as giving
them more of a healthy diet that's what
worked for happy a rather unhappy beagle
when she was 10 she weighed 43 pounds
and was sluggish and unhealthy her new
owner simply walked her more often and
traded healthy snacks for the junk she
used to eat at 14 Happy's a Savelle 28
healthy pounds dr. bender tells us that
even the little things gonna go a long
way to making them healthier cut down on
the number of treats take them for
longer walks or even bring them out to
dog walks like this but it's important
to note that dog and cat breeds are very
different so you should always check
with your vet before you change their
routine or their diet Gail that's very
good advice you know and they also say
that the pets are a reflection of their
owners so I know your girl lifts weights
your dog and I know yours your two are
in very good shape thank you yeah
there's nothing over wait yes wait then
yours is in good shape lucky I know look
younger puppy so she only eats twice a
day that's right
and very many treats kids love lucky as
much as when they first met yes yeah so
they have not been no ammunition in
their love they don't mind about taking
the dog for a walk though yeah it only
grows dog really does become a member of
the family and cats too I understand
Thank You dawn